[Musik]
die phoenix wahlrunde
es ist das kleinste flächenland der
bundesrepublik mit weit weniger als eine
million wahlberechtigten und trotzdem
kommt dieser war wohl eine besondere
bedeutung zu denn es ist die erste
landtagswahl nach der bundestagswahl und
damit für olaf scholz als kanzler und
für friedrich merz als neuen cdu
bundesvorsitzenden insofern darf man
sagen ein stimmungstest auch für das
politische berlin und damit begrüße ich
sie sehr herzlich zu unserer phoenix
wahlrunde in der wir das ergebnis in
ursachen und wirkungen auf die
bundespolitik beleuchten wollen und hier
im studio begrüße ich sehr herzlich
stephan andreas casdorff herausgeber des
tagesspiegel und ich begrüße sehr
herzlich eckart lohse leiter des
parlamentsbüros der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung hier in berlin
herzlich willkommen an sie beide
christoph sprachliche superlative und
floskeln sollte man ja nicht immer
benutzen dennoch wenn nicht heute wann
dann kann man von einem erdrutschsieg
sprechen ja wobei man sagen muss 91
prozent der saarländer ihnen haben
gesagt das hat jetzt mit ukraine oder so
nichts zu tun wenn man denkt das große
wasser dem das kleine mit das hat schon
was mit der kandidatin zu tun also die
sozialdemokratie hat tatsächlich richtig
mit der kandidatin einen großen
siegerehrung ist es für die frau
großartig für die spd großartig noch
eine zahl ich find's großartig 43
prozent finden dass olaf scholz und ganz
guten job machen aber 44 prozent der
saarländerinnen sagen nö nicht so das
heißt viel hat auch mit der performance
der richtigen auswahl mit der
themensetzung in diesem land zu tun das
finde ich auch für die zukünftigen
warten die wir noch von zahlen in diesem
jahr finde ich auch nicht uninteressant
und das aus der position des
juniorpartners senders ja auch
interessant der lose für die einen geht
es 13 prozent nach oben für die anderen
geht es 13 prozent nach unten was
bedeutet das denn für die koalitionäre
wenn man das betrachtet kann man ja
viele fragen an stellen aber so schlecht
kann die politik der landesregierung ja
eigentlich nicht gewesen sein also ich
fand ganz treffend was heiko maas
saarländer der ja auch mal
ministerpräsident werden wollte
verurteilten außenminister heute gesagt
hat
sehr sehr landesspezifische entscheidung
im saarland aber zumindest war das dass
die bundesregierung gemacht hat etwa
beim thema ukraine nicht so dass die
wähler ist glaubten nicht mittragen zu
können also mit anderen worten berlin
hat nicht stark gestört in dieser wahl
die kandidatin hat hat punkten können
der ministerpräsident hat irgendwie
nicht überzeugen können und dann muss
man auch sagen dann geht es ja bei der
kleinen zahl von wählern kann das ja
auch schnell gehen so stark wie der
unterschied ist das ist schon
erstaunlich hat so in der dimension
höchstens in den letzten paar tagen
hätte man das vorher sagen können da war
oder wochen da war klar dass das ist ein
großen unterschied gibt aber noch ende
letzten jahres nicht so was das für
berlin heißt wenn man darüber sprechen
aber
das hat natürlich gerade wenn es so
deutlich ist hat das auch eine gewisse
symbolkraft wir erinnern uns an 2017 als
im saarland der schulz zugleich wollte
scholl dazu ja dass da können wir später
noch zu herkersdorf wir haben es gerade
gehört im november oder zumindest bis
zur bundestagswahl des letzten jahres
lag tobias hans eigentlich sogar noch
vorne in den umfragen das hat sich jetzt
ziemlich drastisch verändert und quasi
umgedreht auch wenn man sich die
persönlichkeitswerte anguckt liegt anke
rehlinger weit weit vor tobias hans was
denn da passiert also wie gesagt du
wirst es in seinem letzten interview
also als ministerpräsident er war immer
der überbringer der schlechten nachricht
die korona politik auch dann bezahlen
wenn das wahr ist was die menschen sagen
dann haben 67 prozent sagt ich habe die
korona politik nicht verstanden und fand
sie nicht mehr gut also am anfang war er
mitglied im team vorsicht also immer
zwei tage 2 1 2 stunden nach nach dem
team führer also markus söder kam er
anhat dann auch stramme einschränkungen
verkündet und plötzlich war das nicht
mehr so und da politik ja im wesen ist
so toll ist cora ich versuche den
menschen zu erklären um die dinge so
sind und warum sie mir bitte dann folgen
mögen man wird dann um zustimmung muss
da irgendwas schiefgelaufen sein sprich
er hat die nicht erreicht er hat die
saarländer in nicht davon überzeugen
können dass eine politik die richtige
sei und dann ist das immer wahrhaben
anfang hier gerade einer von denen die
ständig mit mit ihren warnungen
aufgetaucht sind und auch sehr anerkannt
war aber wie gesagt haben und auch
durchgesetzt aber wenn du dann
lockerungen obwohl schießt dann musst du
sie noch mal das ist das wesen der
politik du musst es wirklich gut
erklären können du musst dann halt eben
sagen wir mal so ich bin jetzt diesem
ergebnis gekommen offensichtlich ist da
was schief gelaufen und dann kann es
auch sein was ja auch schon diskutiert
wird ob die saar-cdu über die jahre
hinweg nun sie haben die haben auch eine
absolute mehrheit gab die regieren ewig
lange jetzt seit über 20 jahren die hat
mit peter müller auch übrigens war einen
der eine absolute mehrheit hatte also da
haben wir gedacht vielleicht läuft das
so und dies offensichtlich die saar-cdu
nicht richtig aufgestellt gewesen der
wahlkampf irgendwie nicht richtig
funktioniert und wenn du dann erklär ich
sag jetzt mal schwächer hast so genau
habe ich das da nicht verfolgt aber wenn
du dann eine erklärt schwäche
offensichtlich hast und du hast keine
partei die ist auf bringt den leuten
sagt so komme ich nehme euch mit social
media oder wie auch immer dann kann so
was passieren das kann nur so gewesen
sein denn sonst ist der absturz nicht
mehr zu erklären ist ja nicht so dass
der auf einmal nicht mehr gut aussieht
oder was anderes gemacht hat sie werden
vakuumiert transgender auch ein stück
weit vielleicht eine fehlbesetzung er
selber ist ja nicht gewählt worden
sondern
er ist von kramp-karrenbauer als
nachfolger ins amt gelangt und hat sich
da bisher noch nicht beweisen müssen das
ist jetzt seine erste wahl das stimmt
das sind wir besonders bitter wenn man
so im lauf übernimmt und dann kommt der
erste test und der geht so in die hosen
noch dazu so wie heute auf der anderen
seite wenn wir jetzt mal nicht
unterstellen dass jeder wähler die
regierungspolitik genau verlegt hat mein
vater wert ist wofür zuständig dann muss
man ja sagen mit der regierung können
sie so wahnsinnig und sophie nicht
gewesen sein sonst wäre frau rehlinger
als führender teil dieser regierung
stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin
nicht da so durch die decke geschossen
heute das heißt es war offensichtlich
sehr an die person gebunden tobias hans
war natürlich auch teil dieses sich über
das gesamte vorige jahr ziehen renke
spiels in der cdu/csu wo es immer hin
und her gehen wer ist für wen diese
ganze saal schlacht
zwischen söder und und laschet und
kandidatur da hat es ja auch noch
mitgespielt der name fiel dauert es kann
natürlich sein dass da auch ein paar
schrammen übrig geblieben sind aber am
ende würde ich sagen wenn ein führendes
mitglied der regierung des saarlandes
heute so
erkennbare wahlsiegerin ist können die
leute nicht der meinung sein dass war
miserables politik in den letzten jahren
also werden wir uns auf die personen
konzentrieren wir sind bei der erklärung
früher hieß es bei der spd immer im
maschinenraum arbeitet und unten hin der
galeere ordentlich rudert und seine
arbeit macht der wird nicht belohnt so
war es über lange lange jahre mit der
spd hat sich das jetzt umgedreht also
zwei sachen ich glaube dass die
saarländerinnen und saarländer das
gefühl hatten das geht den
wirtschaftlich nicht so richtig gut und
da sitzt eine wirtschaftsministerin die
in alu erweckt dass sie das wirklich im
griff hat dass sie wirklich was machen
will und machen kann dass die
durchsetzungsstarke ist das darf man
nicht unterschätzen also sie fühlten
sich bei ihr was die kompetenz angeht
mehr aufgehoben als bei der cdu wenn man
sich mal die kompetenzwerte an wo ist
rasend also die haben der verfall der
cdu das historisch schlecht in allen
altersgruppen und bei allen kompetenzen
in allen altersgruppen und bei allen
kompetenzfeldern sind die hoch gegangen
nur weil endlich glaubt
18 bis 24 jährigen sind sie nur war ein
bein um 1 prozent weil sonst riesig hoch
so dass erst das zweite ist das ist kein
land für slim fit anzüge das ist kein
land für slim fit anzüge das ist die
wollen solche typen haben die da was
darstellen und die zupacken das war auch
halten und nahmen bei annegret kramp
karrenbauer so wir erinnern uns das ist
eine von ihnen gewesen die war dahin die
war die gretel die da aufgetreten als
mayer das natürlich zwei schwergewichten
verloren gegangen seien das war auch bei
dem peter müller so dass in dem tatort
aufgetreten weil jeder peter kannte
tobias hans ist einer für berlin das ist
ein sehr fein formulieren der
ministerpräsident das kommt noch hinzu
und die angelika die hat diese kompetenz
ausgestrahlt die du das ist praktisch
natürlich ist er zugewachsen habe so
dass eine ministerpräsidentin und dann
wirst du gewählt deswegen ich teile das
tut man noch mal angucken müssen das
gilt auch für die kandidaten übrigens
jetzt in den in den anderen ländern da
wird man noch mal hin vergleich noch zu
ich würde mal kurz gerne bei tobias hans
bleiben wir hören gerade slim fit anzug
war das zuviel selbstinszenierung auch
durch diesen ministerpräsidenten
teile durchaus die einschätzung dass war
er einer für berlin hans hatt ja mal
eine gewisse aufmerksamkeit erregt weil
er
angefangen hat auch im gesprochenen wort
zu ändern was nicht alle in der cdu
lustig finden und das war natürlich ein
sehr anderer typ als die sonst
prominenten cdu saarländer die wir
hatten kamen jetzt auch nach der
bundestagswahl hinzu dass eben zwei
verdienen nämlich altmaier und kam bei
ihrer mandate nicht wahrgenommen haben
die sie per liste hätten kriegen können
die aber dann sieht man
vernünftigerweise gesagt haben das
lassen wir mal die jüngeren leuten die
sind da abhandengekommen heiko maas
übrigens vom typ her ja nicht ganz
unähnlich also jetzt mal nur vom
auskommen wenn wir über slim fit anzüge
reden
ist ja auch eher ein berliner hat es ja
auch irgendwie nicht so hingekriegt im
saarland also möglicherweise kann das
auch ein teil der erklärung sein
im falle tobias stichwort
selbstinszenierung bei tobias hans wir
sprechen mal kurz über das tankstellen
video fast sechs millionen mal geklickt
worden aber hat bei den saarländerinnen
nicht so verfahren wie wir denken wir
denken aber ich glaube die gerade dabei
waren uns besser als wir haben sehr gut
von in dem land hat sehr schlimm daran
hat sich gelegt außerdem wenn man genau
hinguckt ja da gibt es gibt also wenn
man ganz piggy ist dann ist ja auch ein
social media hoch und runter gelaufen
also ein ganz genau so haltet also die
armen und die die wirklich arbeiten so
da hatte ein gegensatz vermeintlich
aufgehört das meinte er nicht so so dass
das 1 die saarländer haben das schon
richtig verstanden das übrigens ein sehr
westdeutsch geprägtes land das so
richtig wie früher da werden die
volksparteien noch gewählt da sind sie
dem noch volksparteien das ist
katholisch die meisten sind katholisch
also wenn ja das ist auch noch kirchlich
stark organisiert also das ist richtig
noch so altes westdeutschland so das ist
ein darlehen und heraus glaube nicht
genau eben deswegen sag ja dieses
anpacken zu packen und so dass noch ein
bisschen so ja was wir aber ich will das
sagen selbst inszeniere sich glaube ich
gar nicht mal denn mit diesem ein
argument mit den spritpreisen erhalten
so genannten so ganz falsch liegt er
nicht 2008 100 und 50 us-dollar pro
barrel öl
super 1 liter 1,58
140 us dollar pro barrel öl also 10
weniger habe der super-preis 232 worauf
wollte der 232 das ist eine diskrepanz
darauf wollte der tobias hans
aufmerksamer das hat hat der recht
gehabt aber auch da noch mal das machst
du nicht in einem kurzen kleinen
filmchen sondern du musst den leuten
schon erklären wo es herkommt ableitung
schaffen erklären woher kommt die leute
mitnehmen mal so ein kleines filmchen zu
machen oder auf twitter 280 zeichen
abzusetzen das musst du das ist ja wie
eschenburg dass er große politik auf
begriffe gebracht hilfe das darf dann
wirklich nicht daneben gehen und
irgendwie bei uns in berlin ist es
falsch angekommen die säulenhalle
missverstanden und trotzdem das glaube
ich war es nicht und selbstinszenierung
das ist ein großes holz zwar sei es dass
tobias hans wenig
wenig unterstützung von seiten der
bundes cdu bekam also friedrich merz hat
man jetzt nicht so besonders häufig im
wahlkampf gesehen weil das ziel
friedrich merz als friedrich merz
vorsitzender war hat er schon gemerkt
das ging
in die hosen gehen da wollen wir uns mal
lieber rudern wir mal ein bisschen weg
von einem schiff was zumindest schon mal
schlingert und vielleicht sinkt also
anders als die spd-spitze die da ja auch
noch mal darum kramp karrenbauer war ja
diejenigen die ursprünglich auch cdu
vorsitzende war tobias hans war dann
immer mehr auf kramp karrenbauer seite
war da noch alte rechnungen auf zwischen
tobias ans erste jetzt hat sich auf die
seite in der pandemie von markus söder
gestellt also wenn es so zu sagen wenn
wir es darauf auf konflikte mal
konzentrieren würde man sagen also da
war vielleicht noch eine rechnung offen
heute klappt das ja ganz gut mit mit
söder und märz aber es gab zeiten da war
märz auf leute die sich an die seite
soll das stellt nicht so gut zu sprechen
und dass das war ja dann er so ich
glaube dass mit kramp karrenbauer das
ist dann auch irgendwann
vorbei hans war da ja so
lange auf ihrer seite dann wie gesagt
auf söder seite also das war ja nicht so
ganz klar
basierte unionswähler dass da nicht so
richtig einigkeit ist das hat der
unionswähler natürlich das ganze letzte
jahr mit einer solchen wucht vorgemacht
bekommen man kann ja das ergebnis für
friedrich merz oder
muss es auch in einem erheblichen maße
damit erklären dass diese seit 218
laufende saalschlacht in der union das
war natürlich viele unionswähler leid
die hatten einfach keine lust mehr auf
das bundestagswahlergebnis hat mit
vielen zu tun aber auch damit dass die
unionswähler sagten das ist einfach ein
riesenstreit haufen da ein hühnerhaufen
und da war natürlich hans als
ministerpräsident teil des ganzen ging
ja auch gar nicht anders so also das ist
bestimmt auch mit hängen geblieben und
die spd hat halt das glück dass die
hühner hoffen rolle jetzt mal gewechselt
ist diese ja lange zeit mit viel kraft
behauptet haben und frau rehlinger ist
stellvertretende spd vorsitzende ist
viel aufgetaucht bei spd parteitagen man
konnte die sehen konnte die auch
bundespolitisch sehen sind auch alle zu
ihr gekommen war eine gute mischung ja
ja ja ja
ja
ja ja die wissen schon auch was das
bedeutet ich sage dass gruppen vor hin
dass das große wasser das kleine ist
natürlich schon auch so dass alle jetzt
sagen dass es laufen natürlich ein
ausweis für die herausragend gute
politik der ampel in berlin also das
wird dann auch noch mit gewürdigt werden
das ist nicht ganz so also wenn wir da
rein gucken so in das kabinett und da
gibt es auch einige gefahren würde ich
mal sagen und zu anderen zeiten würde
das auch zu irgendwelchen personellen
konsequenzen geführt haben aber ist
nicht so nein das nochmal ich will noch
mal vor heben das ist ein herausragender
erfolg der spitzenkandidatin die fanden
die richtig gut und das ist das was dem
saarland suchen und ich glaube sagen zu
dürfen dass das auch das ist was in
anderen bundesländern jetzt das ist die
das ist die folgerung daraus was in
anderen und die frage ist das ist das
eine singularität dann im saarland oder
erleben wir das was wir 2017 schon
erlebt haben erst ging die saarland wahl
an die cdu dann gegen schleswig holstein
wahl an die cdu dann die nordrhein
westfalen wahl an die cdu und die
bundestagswahl dann auch gleich wer das
jetzt so eine kette für die spd diesmal
also mit umgekehrten vorzeichen die cdu
jetzt den fehler man sich intern wieder
zu zerlegen dann kann das so sein ja
also im moment ist es ja so wird
vielleicht nie siegen also wird
vielleicht nicht weiter
ministerpräsident sein können aber wird
gewinnen möchte weil die stärkste
fraktion stellen das ist ja schon mal
was sodann wird der daniel günther
möglicherweise wieder gewählt weil das
da ja gut läuft in schließlich hat schon
jedenfalls sieht das so aus und dann ist
das so somit somit so würde ich mal
sagen ziemlich gut und ich glaube dass
die cdu der ein man muss auch mal sagen
ob tobias landwirten der einzige der in
der cdu in dieser saalschlacht
irgendwann mal gesagt jetzt reicht's
aber mal war übrigens friedrich merz der
gesagt hat mit markus söder jetzt ist er
ganz schön wenn du für uns wahlkampf
machen wolltest und nicht für die
sozialdemokraten das hat man von tobias
hans nicht gehört und wenn die leute
etwas goutieren dann ist es schon wenn
also jetzt ist aber mal gut scheint er
jetzt ist mal jetzt ist mal gut mit so
was und ich glaube dass ein teil des
wahlergebnisses auch genau damit zu tun
die gott wann es satt mit dem streit da
kommt einer seit jetzt schluss und dann
verspricht einer führung wie auch immer
die dann aussieht darüber kann man ja
immer noch geteilter meinung sein aber
der macht das jetzt und deswegen haben
sie im märz gewählt und deswegen haben
sie möglicherweise in tobias hansen
nicht gewählt weil da eben die
kompetente hochkompetente
gegenkandidaten waren sagt die wirtin
unterstellt dass wir nach der schleswig
holstein wahl am 8 am abend des 8
auch wer in dieser runde sitzen können
wir dann noch mal kurz darüber sprechen
weil daniel günther schleswig holstein
hat sich ja nun auch extrem in dieser
schlacht eingemischt also immer gerade
in den ganzen corona streit also mal
gucken wenn das so ist und wenn das dann
nicht langsam mal vergessen ist dann
wäre das ein film muss ich meine worte
auf ist aber ich glaube ja vielleicht
auch das aber naja haben sich in klarer
weise eingemischt es geht mir nicht
darum dass sie gar nichts sagen sondern
dass sie eine klare position beziehen es
hilft nix entweder ja oder nein ist ja
oft so am ende ist es entweder ja oder
nein bist du auf der seite von armin
laschet und möchtest dass der vielleicht
dann doch irgendwie bundeskanzler wird
oder möchtest du es nicht und da hatte
man bei einigen in der union den
eindruck dass sie alles wollten nur das
nicht und das ist natürlich auch schon
sagen kann unions wähler überhaupt ein
unions sympathisanten klar für einen
mitglied die vollkatastrophe dann könnt
ihr dann 1 kurz noch zum saarland als
eine erklärung sozusagen eine sehr
von oben eine erklärung sagen vielleicht
gefällt den saarländer ist auch ganz gut
wenn so gebaut alle zwei jahrzehnte das
ist ja nicht mathematisch exakt aber so
ungefähr wechseln sich diese beiden
volksparteien da ab das ist ja wohl die
stabilität auch der bundesrepublik so
schlecht nicht gewesen wird jetzt ist
das mal wieder so welt nicht unter und
möglicherweise ist das auch gar nicht so
kontrovers sondern dass man auch jetzt
sind die andern mal wieder dran können
so sagt es das dann für tobias hans was
erwarten sie denn morgen wird er von
allen ämtern zurücktreten wird nicht als
kleiner koalitionspartner falls die spd
worten koalitionspartner braucht
in eine koalition gehen der dann von
tobias hans nichts mehr hören er hat ja
schon eine weile gelegenheit gehabt
längere strecke sich klar zu machen dass
er aller voraussicht nach nicht
ministerpräsident bleibt habe vor ein
paar tagen noch behauptet er kann auch
die wahl gewinnen aber da habe ich auch
gedacht donnerwetter das ist nicht meine
kollegen aus den 17
habt kam aber als jahre torschuss 10 10
10 prozent wenige tage vor der wahl also
das ist mal egal kann sich das gründlich
überlegt haben das spricht natürlich
viel dafür nach so einer wahlniederlage
zu sagen ich überlege mir was neues
aber andererseits ist ihm auch aus der
spd heute gedanken ich weiß es nicht
möglicherweise sagte auch ich halte
jetzt eine weile durch und mache jetzt
mal den minister für irgendwas im
saarland wette wenn sie meine wette
abnötigen würden würde ich dann doch
eher auf
einen rückzug zu retten aber nicht
meinen ganzen verein wie sie da kommt
der rückzug und so
glauben sie es kommt der rückzug und wie
groß ist der druck aus berlin also in
der krise findet das rettende sich auch
ich glaube nicht dass er das also ist es
normal dimension des geschehens
hierarchie de argument das ist eine
historische und historisch schlechte
historisch schlechtes ergebnis für die
cdu also schlecht schlechter waren sie
noch nie da so wenn das wahr ist dann
kann der nicht im amt bleiben da muss
irgend eine die verantwortung von dem
ist die frage wer dann kommt das weiß
ich nicht aber ich sage ja eine krise
findet das rennen das ich auch einer
muss das kreuzbein und so ich übernehme
jetzt die verantwortung das ist ich
glaube auch nicht dass friedrich merz
tobias hans drängen wird im amt zu
bleiben den eindruck konnte man ja jetzt
wie der kollege lose auch gesagt hat in
der zurückliegenden nicht
notwendigerweise bekommen dass er alles
daran setzt weil er auch schon gedacht
hatten ja das wird jetzt nichts mehr und
bei zehn prozentpunkte dahinter also
auch in allen umfragen was die
persönlichkeitswerte angeht war ja nix
mehr zu reisen sonst hätte man ja
vielleicht noch irgendwie denken können
na ja irgendwie durch ein wunder also
schröder merkel plötzlich 34 2 zu finden
also irgendwie aber dabei nicht
darin einmischen der wird jetzt mal für
eine woche so tun als gäbe es nur 15
bundesländer und er weiß nicht genau was
saarland ist ein sagt macht geht es mal
also auch nach der nach der explosion
geräumt das mal alleine
ja aber wird nicht viel zu tun du wirst
hans zu halten weder suche noch so das
macht ja wahrscheinlich gehen davon aus
dass sie in die regierung kommen ich
glaub ja nicht also nach also so wie es
aussieht kann die spd ja sogar alleine
ja hier machen sie doch mal auf die spd
also nachdem wir so lange die cdu
betrifft haben also mögliche absolute
mehrheit durch die spd da knallen
überall die sektkorken vor allen dingen
auch in berlin also nach den vielen
schlappen die die spd in den vielen
vielen letzten jahren hatte jetzt mal
abgesehen von der bundestagswahl ist das
doch mehr als balsam auf die seele oder
also die spd ist ja eine in einer
wahnsinnig schwierigen lage das ist ja
im moment noch so ein bisschen gedeckelt
von einem von einem weltereignis was uns
allen täglich durch die knochen fährt
aber wenn man das mal sich mal
vorstellen dass das der gewöhnungseffekt
so grauenhaft es klingt ein bisschen
mehr ein bettler politik ist dass sie
irgendwann
passiert das so dann sind irgendwann
kommen wieder andere themen so und dann
muss die spd sachen verdauen die jetzt
aufs gleis gesetzt worden sind die
normalerweise von der spd programmatik
so weit entfernt sind wie wir vom mars
das heißt diese dinge die bleiben ja der
stolz sagt ja nicht wenn sich irgendwie
was tatsächlich
gefunden hat ein waffen
also das ist natürlich das wichtigste
das größte aber das sind ja auch noch
andere sachen da sind ja mittlere und
kleine samt zwei lng terminals wie lange
wehrt sich unter anderem zwei reichte
der landesverband vielleicht so leicht
zum 3 schleswig holstein der grünen dem
der wirtschaftsminister abeck angehört
habe gesagt nein nein macht man nicht
auf einmal machte scholz sonntags passau
4 1 habe ich noch also 100 milliarden
und dann haben wir ich lege auch noch
zwei lng terminals oft das muss ja alles
gemacht werden dazu muss zugestimmt
werden im moment ist das noch kein thema
im moment ist das alles ein solcher
schock unter denen auch die regierungen
steht aber das wird irgendwann weniger
und dann kann der scholz natürlich jeden
wahlsieg auch ein klein war saarland
absolute mehrheit das ist natürlich
alles das
federt das ein bisschen ab niemand
behauptet olaf scholz hat die sein
anwalt und das wird er selber nicht mal
sagen er hat sie aber nicht verloren sie
ist in seiner zeit nicht verloren worden
es gibt einen dicken pluspunkt in der
spd also von daher haben die heute
morgen da ja und was ist denn das die
spd klientel damit geht
ja den olaf scholz der kann schon noch
aushalten also das schon toll also der
sagt was er tut und tut was er sagen und
dann sollen ja nochmal sehen die grünen
die spd linken die können sie auf den
kopf stellen die können sich auf den
kopf stellen die coolen ist das wird
irgendwann kult werden das wird
irgendwann konnte diese coolen ist das
einfach so auszusitzen auszuhalten story
ein vertreter des neuen stalinismus in
der politik das werden die leute
irgendwann mal toll finden übrigens
einst wird die wird die spd auch noch
und die linke der spd auch noch freuen
im saarland hat sich gezeigt dass du die
linke schlagen und zurück holen kannst
gucken wir uns doch mal die wähler
wahrzunehmen also den kleinen parteien
kommen
immerhin oskar lafontaine das war ihre
drei vorsitz war in die absolut so und
jetzt sind sie von 12,8 auf 2,5 gestürzt
du kannst sie kriegen und das ist für
die sozialdemokratie ein enormes es gar
zum fanal kann sich die linke stellen
würde trotzdem gerne nochmal bei der spd
ein stück weit bleiben man kennt das ein
stück weiter bei der spd was sie gerade
beschrieben haben dass der regierende
kanzler
nicht unbedingt einig ist mit dem was
die spd basis und die partei eigentlich
will oder die partei vor gibt schröder
war da auch in köln rolf mützenich alle
sind auf der seite des bundeskanzlers
niemand sagen sie das glück gibt es da
wirklich so eine geschlossenheit also
wenn man den fraktionsvorsitz im
bundestag gehört hat oder wenn man den
generalsekretär hört dann ist im moment
diese politik wie ich sagen
alternativlos aber alle erkennen an dass
es unter den obwaltenden umständen keine
andere politik gibt aber da sagt herr
lohse im moment ist es so dass ich habe
mich in der bei der bundestagsdebatte
folge auch anders gehört das war nämlich
der moment sagt er natürlich froh
polieren nicht gegen meinen eigenen
kanzler ich erinnere aber an die alten
werte die wir in der außenpolitik und
zwar das heißt im grunde genommen diesen
jetzt gehts grad nicht an und alle
machen mit aber das heißt ja nicht dass
es ein nein auch die größte die jahre
aber wir müssen ja auch gucken was sagen
meine eigenen leute von wem werde ich
getragen wir wissen ja bis heute noch
nicht ganz genau wie funktioniert diese
spd-fraktion die ist zur überwiegend
neue leute eigentlich sehr viele junge
leute die alle selber ehren man muss
sich das mal vorstellen da ist ein
junger bundestagsabgeordneter und der
wird im oktober da rein gewählt und dann
wäre jemand gekommen von uns und hätte
gesagt ende februar hat und sich zu
sonntag ein schönes weißes hemd an und
setzt sich dahin und dann sagt ihr der
bundeskanzler wir hauen 100 milliarden
für die rüstung raus du stehst auf und
klatscht denn hätte der gesagt gib dem
alten mann medikamente da ist was schief
bei dem so die sind ja alle noch da die
müssen sich ja alle erst mal sortieren
sich das allemal gründlich angucken und
dann können wir beurteilen gut wie große
rückhalt für israel werden aber der
führung bei mir bestellt bekommt sie
auch so jetzt hat er geführt in einer
schwierigen situation es konnte nur ein
sozialdemokratischer bundeskanzler
machen wenn das ein christdemokrat
gewesen wäre der mensch straßen voll
gewesen um gottes willen jetzt kommt
dialektik und da ist die spd wirklich
begabt und olaf scholz ehemals stark ab
der kennt das auch alles also der kann
sagen es ist keine aufrüstung meine
lieben freund wird wir holen nur nach
was aber versprochen worden ist von
einem sozialdemokratischen außenminister
namens steinmeier im nord zusammenhang
was alle bundesregierung bestätigt haben
dass wir überall immer gesagt haben dass
prozent wir machen das jetzt mal zwei
prozent das ist ein versprechen
versprochen gehalten das kommt immer gut
an das kommt vor allen dingen bei
sozialdemokratischen wählerinnen und
wählern gut an weil das ja nicht nur
sagen wir mal
universitätsprofessoren sind sondern da
geht das gesprochen und das gehaltene
wort dass das erst das zweite ist die
bundeswehr wird nicht aufgerüstet mit
nee nee wer sich ein bisschen auskennt
der wird nur ausgerüstet wenn wir
schiffe haben die nicht fahren wenn wir
panzer haben den ich rollen wenn wir ja
ich muss ja nicht alles wieder sagt um
zu fliegen und wenn das gewehr auch noch
um die ecke schießt aber dann ist es nur
gut dass die bundeswehr irgendwann mal
zudem ausgestattet wird wozu sie sonst
können wir sagen wir machen früher war
das glaube ich costa rica wir wollen
keine bundeswehr mehr haben wir wollen
polizei aus besser ausstatten das reich
mit der mit der mitte aber so lange wie
eine armee haben und so lange wir
glauben dass sie notwendig sei da
sollten wir sie auch so ausstatten dass
sie ihren auftrag erfüllen kann und das
passiert jetzt nicht mehr nicht weniger
das kann man doch oder nicht also mein
verehrter herr castorf was machen die
mit dem geld zb eine der ersten großen
entscheidungen wir aktualisieren unser
vermögen der nuklearen teilhabe wie
viele wahlkämpfer rot und grün waren
gegen die new yorker teilhabe und jetzt
werden es 30 flugzeuge chance wie diese
die bundesministerinnen des auch
heiligen können ja für die nukleare
teilhabe
neuerdings seien neuerdings aber die
glaube ich eine grüne ich glaube die
grünen jetzt
auch nur ausrüstung also das sind jetzt
nicht für 100 milliarden helfen sondern
das sind in der sich auch die grünen und
das wird ja diese waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine werden durch wen genehmigt
durch das bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und wenn ich mich recht
entsinne sitzen wer ein grüner heißt die
spd sieht sich an der seite derer die
vernünftig damit umgehen was ich nicht
verstehen kann ist nebenbei gesagt ich
vielleicht jetzt kein riesen posten wir
haben uns angewöhnt es geht nur noch 100
milliarden aber was sie nicht verstehen
kann ist dass man den entwicklungshilfe
etat um 1,57 milliarden kürzen will also
da muss ich sagen da habe ich gar kein
verständnis da zivilgesellschaftlich und
was weiß ich da wollen wir vielleicht
dann doch auch noch ein bisschen geld da
einbringen das war immer von erhard
eppler irgendjemand weiß wie es ist ein
ganz großer vordenker der spd bis heute
ist das eine domäne der spd und svenja
schulze wird sich bedanken vielleicht
ist das jetzt im zuge der
haushaltsberatungen irgendwie so weg
deshalb würde ich gerne noch mal zurück
den saal ein und auch zu den grünen die
jetzt gerade schon stichwort waren die
grünen sind gerade mal so eben wenn
überhaupt richtig drin im saarländischen
landtag
15 prozent sind zeit also dass das ist
immer noch so ein bisschen auf der kippe
ist noch nicht endgültig stets fest aber
nichtsdestotrotz 5 prozent damit können
ja die grünen nicht zufrieden sein ist
das noch ein saarländisches phänomen ich
glaube was sozusagen die kunst der
selbstzerstörung angeht sind die
saarländischen grünen ja in einer skala
von 1 bis 10 immer so platz neun oder
noch halten uns in der bundestagswahl
konnten sie dann ganz groß ganz großem
selbstverständnis insofern ja das ist
glaube ich schon auch ein spezifikum der
saarländischen grünen denn ansonsten
wären wir bundesweit gucken wurde auch
in andere bundesländer gucken sie das ja
ein bisschen anders aus da würde ich
jetzt mal sagen sollten die schaffen
reinzukommen mit 5,0 sehr doll und komma
1 wenn ich noch würden die
wahrscheinlich die erste hälfte der
legislaturperiode sekt trinken und dann
werden es da haben sie ja vielleicht gar
nicht mitgerechnet insofern der kasse
jetzt versuche ich gerade ausgetreten
gehen also nochmal aber nochmal der
beweis dafür dass dieser länder nicht
auf die bundespolitik gucken oder
wenn man schon mit einer art von frau
berbalk unterlag anguckt sind es ja
nicht die saarländer sind nicht wenig
vertreten der bundespolitik irgendwie
muss man ja sagen die sind ja schon
immer irgendwie einflussreich gewesen
alles also krank waren bei lafontaine
altmaier peter müller maß überall sind
die saarländer ist also irgendwie haben
die ja was und ja bei den grünen finde
ich auch faszinierend da ist jetzt
gerade der kurzzeit landesvorsitzende co
landesvorsitz ich habe fünf tage abend
und dann ist das ist gerade ausgetreten
hat alle ämter niedergelegt auch in
hamburg oder wo auch immer also das ist
schon wirklich ganz toll das ist so ein
bisschen so wie die afg die haben gar
keinen spitzenkandidaten
und trotzdem irgendwie reingekommen und
die die linke hat sich ja da auch
polarisiert also das schon doch mal 38
bleiben wir mal ein bisschen beiden
grünen also man kann dieses ergebnis der
bundespolitischen performance in der
ampel bei den grünen denen nicht
wirklich anlass
dass die reinkommen ist schon gut und
das würde ich mal sagen hat er mit dem
bund zu tun als mit dem land denn da geh
ich habe muss ich gestehen den wahlkampf
von lisa becker das ist die
spitzenkandidatin nicht wirklich
verfolgt das muss ich sagen aber es war
bestimmt nicht hinderlich dass die
grünen im bund so regieren also die
spitzen grünen die waren die waage wie
wirklich wahrgenommenen grünen also
baerbock habe cakewalk dass diese formen
wie man neudeutsch sagt wie sie wie sie
es tun diese da wirklich enorm dominant
und scheinen das ja auch dort zu machen
dann sagen die gruner jahr so schlimm
kann das nicht sein auch hier bei uns
nicht sagen mal so da glaube ich hat es
schon ein gewissen einen gewissen wert
gehabt also die waren bestimmt nicht
hinderlich für das ergebnis wenn es über
fünf prozent kommen das heißt dann wenn
grünen realo
und würde das wird das noch gar nicht
wird es ja nicht so dass man ist ja auch
das ist ja eine eine
gesamtanalyse die ich teile denn der
große trick des paars berbalk oder des
gespanns berbalk habe ist ja dass sie im
grunde genommen diesen alten
mechanismus aufgelöst haben dass man
auch da war ich also noch
parteivorsitzende waren
real is so die haben fantastische
umfragewerte und stehen ganz gut da also
insgesamt ist das ja bei den grünen dass
wir jetzt vielleicht auch mal uns ein
bisschen abgewöhnen zuseher immer auf
1990 folgende zu gucken wo das noch wie
sozusagen wie ich haben konnte man war
ja also in sachen bis jetzt also das ist
ja
wahnsinnig republik lassen die
saarländischen grünen sind echt ein
spezialfall sorgt
insgesamt ist natürlich festzustellen
dass er den grünen und das werden wir
vielleicht ja auch bei denen bei den
jungen grünen feststellen dass natürlich
da viele
gemein gesamten gemeinde gesagt links
denken aber reale und links ist glaube
ich nicht mehr ein ideologischer graben
wie ist ihnen gab also das war nicht
mehr so zugehörigkeiten wie trittin
fischer damals sondern das ist
sehr viel vereinbaren und die diese
lager sind ja nicht mehr so ausgeprägt
also vor der burg und
natürlich tut sie das haben wir auch
eben gesprochen aber also also frau
werbung herberg verbringen ja nicht
wesentliche teil ihrer arbeitszeit mit
realo treffen also wir haben ja noch
etwas anderes zu tun das ist auch
einfach nicht mehr so schauen wir mal
auf die linke saarland war mal eine
hochburg der linken durch lafontaine
jetzt
längst nicht im laden war dem landtag
drin mit 25 prozent in der
bundestagswahl hatte die linke auch
schon ein wenig geschlottert überhaupt
in den bundestag einziehen zu können was
bedeutet das denn für die linke sind die
linken generell im niedergang also da
müssen wir dann glaube ich schon relativ
präzise
westdeutschland aus deutschland
unterscheiden der niedergang der linken
in den westdeutschen landtagen oder auch
bei bundestagswahl ergebnissen ist ja
eklatant also verloren hat ja die linke
diese bundestagswahlen diese wenn es
werden wir nicht dieses wahlsystem
hätten und die sonderregelung das war
mit drei direktmandaten in den bundestag
kommt verloren haben wir vor allen
dingen im westen da ist die partei im
grunde genommen das war heute ein
letzter stempel der vielleicht noch
drauf gesetzt werden musste also wenn
sie im saarland bei 2,1 landen kann man
sagen das thema ist in westdeutschland
weitestgehend erledigt aber natürlich
findet sie in den ostdeutschen ländern
und landtagen noch stadt zum teil auch
sehr stark stellt einen
ministerpräsidenten
immerhin also das muss man glaube ich
sehr unterscheiden was das für die
nächste bundestagswahl heißt können wir
jetzt noch nicht sagen wenn es dann
wieder drei mandate gibt irgendwo sind
sie wieder drin aber nicht vergessen
eigentlich wären sie nicht im bundestag
davor ist es richtig war der vorletzte
stempel um mal das aufzugreifen aus der
dose gerade gesagt hat für die linke der
austritt von oskar lafontaine
also er hat ja damals die wehr ist geht
zur pds geführt und dann haben sich für
eigentlich zur linken gemacht zu fünf
folgen mit gysi zusammen das war schon
gut bisky gysi das ist ja die sind ja
also gut wie sieht es noch so das sind
die namen die noch einen großen klang
hatten und jetzt
das war schon auch die hatte links von
der spd so eine partei das hat ja auch
seinen sinn irgendwie war ja nicht alles
sagen wir aus der luft geholt dass wir
hatten ja ihre themen aber tatsache ist
dass sie themen jetzt andere sind und
dass die spd nehmen wir an macht mit dem
mit dem generalsekretär kevin kühnert
die die programme hat in der spd wird
sich so sagen wir mal
anpassen können variieren dass sie die
linke obsolet machen weil die jetzt auch
angeschlagen sind wer vertritt denn
jetzt im ernst wer also wert hier so
sitzt und sein wer ist denn der
vertrauensanker der linken in der
bundesdeutschen bevölkerung sind das die
beiden parteivorsitzenden ist dass der
herr bartsch wer ist das und wer hat am
ende alle enden wer sagt uns buch für
die partei entsteht und dann kommt immer
auch noch sarah wagenknecht dann lieber
gott wo bin ich jetzt hier also das ja
ein kräfte parallelogramm und wir wollen
uns damit beschäftigen ob die jetzt so
oder so sind und da kommt die spd da
sage ich mal vielleicht ist es
tatsächlich also hitze nicht als
vertreter der der pragmatischen linken
würde ich mal sagen aber das ist ja auch
wiederum eine chance wenn der rolf
mützenich als fraktionschef so redet wie
er redet wem spricht eher aus dem herzen
den linken und zwar nicht nur in der spd
also als strategischen generalsekretär
der partei kann es gar nicht besser
laufen du hast einen höchst
pragmatischen bundeskanzler der
unglaublich aushalten kann nicht gleich
beleidigt ist wenn irgendeiner
interessiert weil er gar nicht reagiert
das ist anders als schröder der wurde
dann wütend nein der wird gar nicht
wütend das musst du erst mal aushalten
so das ist der eine und dann hast du
einen pragmatischen linken als
fraktionschef und dann hast du einen
vordenker der linken im amt des
generalsekretärs ist eine eigentlich
muss man sagen eine ideale wirklich eine
nahezu ideale aufstellung für die
nächste bundestagswahl deswegen machen
die das im übrigen auch als ich dass die
linke hat den generationenwechsel
einfach schlecht nicht hingekriegt oder
ist es so dass die inhalte eben
tatsächlich wirklich einfach wechseln
also nochmal lassen wenn wir über die
die linke den niedergang sprechen über
die westdeutsche sprechen die hatten
natürlich auch ganz viel mit lafontaine
und wagenknecht zu tun und irgendwo wäre
so ein bisschen spaß an historischen
analogien hat also das jetzt gerhard
schröder und oskar lafontaine sozusagen
gleichzeitig in der versenkung
verschwinden aus unterschiedlichen
gründen hat ja irgendwie auch was zu
sagen lafontaine war natürlich für die
für den westdeutschen teil der linken
eine identifikationsfigur ohne eine
rache figur für die spd eine rache für
hartz4 eine rache figur für gerhard
schröder so die beiden verschwinden
jetzt weil die themen natürlich
irgendwann auch mal durch sind schröder
hat noch eine eigene methode sich zu
versenken aber bei lafontaine ist es ja
auch es gibt nicht mehr diese riesen
erregung über das thema hartz iv die ist
langsam mal durch wobei er mit den
themen schon recht hat also darf die
rennen also dass die geringverdiener
nicht vergessen das ist sein
lieblingsthema und damit hat er recht
außerdem ist das gelernt mindestlohn 12
euro und
das regierungshandeln bei der
pragmatischen linken bei der ist wie das
haben wir aber sagen so niemand konnte
das tatsächlich oder weniger konnte so
gut erklären wir oskar lafontaine mann
der mit einer rede die gesamte partei
umdrehen kann das findet sich in bei der
linken heute so nicht das gibt so nicht
und das ist natürlich eine qualität die
die also fragen wir uns mal qualität die
die so nicht mehr haben und natürlich
kann der ja denken das ist ja so dass
weiß ja auch jeder und er war immer
vorzeitig hat viele ideen gehabt die
dann nachher tatsächlich wirklichkeit
wurden nur das war halt zu der zeit
vielleicht nicht das was die leute
verstanden haben oder wo sie dafür
stimmen irgendwann hat aber auch der
wohl meinte verstanden dass das ein
zerstörer typ ist lafontaine zerstört
wenn man sie als luzifer so die
motivation für die gründung der
linkspartei der zusammenführung war
immer auch nach aber wenn die spd wenn
lafontaine ist geschafft hätte kanzler
zu werden 1998 hätte er niemals diese
partei gegründet das ist ein cent
gewesen so und das handeln also wie auch
schon alle verstellbar kommen da kann
man mal von den linken zur fdp sieht
jetzt aus dass sie eher nicht drin ist
geht er ein bisschen runter 4,8 sind die
neuesten hochrechnung zahlen was
bedeutet das denn es gibt ja immerhin
die ampel in der bundesrepublik im bund
eigentlich lindner hat als
finanzminister die große bühne das hätte
doch eigentlich für die fdp auch einen
ausschlag geben können und vor allem die
fdp hat sich im saarland ja durchaus im
vergleich zu manch anderer partei
geschlossen dargestellt es gibt aber
scheint unsere these zu bekräftigen dass
es letztendlich sehr
landesspezifische gründe
gibt für den ausgang dieser wahl und
dass die zahlen für die fdp im bund ja
gut zwischen gut und sehr gut sind die
stellen für bundesminister die stellen
einen omnipräsenten finanzminister dass
das
heute an den wahlen keine große rolle
gespielt hat sonst wäre das zumindest
irgendwo bei 6 prozent gelandet
offenbar auch da was heißt das denn für
die ampel für die jetzt guter dritter
das grüne und fdp jetzt nicht so
reduzieren könnten im saarland oder ist
spielt es keine rolle das wird sich so
nicht also das ganze ist ein pluspunkt
haben wir brauchen für die spd und nicht
schön natürlich für die anderen aber
dass das dauerhaft folgen hat etwa für
grüne und gelbe im bund kann nicht mehr
im moment nicht vorstellen die ard hat
noch nicht besprochen
auch ihr afd ähnlich wie die anderen
kleinen parteien um die fünf prozent
aber fünf mit 5,5 in der jetzigen
hochrechnungen doch schon
sicher drin aber
die fdp ist ja auch andere zahlen
gewöhnt ja ja eigentlich also jetzt
nicht mehr spitzenkandidaten trotzdem
semenya das zeigt ja da gibt es halt was
normal also auch so ein bisschen
westdeutsch da ein bisschen rechts von
der cdu kannst du auch noch was geben
und die cdu ist schwach ist ja so also
jedenfalls im saarland ist wir haben
zeit in die dämmung dem demokratischen
wechsel das finden wir auch gut aber
irgendwie so schwachen am leute gesagt
nee die sind irgendwie ausgesprochen
vielleicht aber auch die afd
wird jetzt weniger werden das glaube ich
schon also also es ist ja so dass sie
mal sein wollte mit dem
ökonomieprofessor und mit seinem look
und anderen das was sie mal sagen das
ist ja nicht mehr der von der wfg und
die leute gesagt haben ja das ist mal
das ist sind bei dem noch konservative
nicht rechte sondern das sind eben noch
richtige konservative das ist ja so
nicht mehr seien wir mal ehrlich also
wenn wenn
die von dem verfassungsschutz
betrachtet werden ich mache das für eine
partei die sind jetzt durch zufall immer
noch ein parlament und so aber das teilt
sich ja mit und es teilt sie auch mit
wer da jetzt das sagen hat und wir das
sagen übernimmt und das kann sein dass
wenn man das richtig wenn man da richtig
angreift und wenn die cdu dieses
bürgerliche tatsächlich im besten sinne
bürgerliche den bürgerlichen
konservativismus beleben kann also das
mit anstand und seriosität und solidität
und nicht übertreibung mitfühlenden
konservativismus dann kann das der afd
tatsächlich anhalts gehen auch da wir
natürlich die unterscheidung west ost
denn alles was ich sagen trifft auf
weite teile auch nicht alle teile baden
württemberg würde ich ein bisschen
anders sehen aber weite teile der
westdeutschen länder zu abwind half den
sagte wir haben in den meisten
ostdeutschen ländern noch zahlen wo wir
die luft und wie gesagt haben wir haben
dann zwei
kleinen parteien im westen wie im osten
natürlich groß bisher aber auch da ist
da ist ja nicht so als ob der osten 80
millionen wären ich glaube das bleibt
nicht unbeeinflusst davon sind so viel
wie nordrhein-westfalen ja so also die
bleiben sie die wählerinnen und wähler
da bleiben nicht unbeeinflusst von dem
was ich im bundesgebiet abspielt und das
glauben aber
da war fast am ende der sendung
klose würde ich gerne noch so ein blick
auf den bund werfen saarland hat gewählt
was bedeutet das denn
irgendwelche verschiebungen gegeben ist
es irgendetwas ist die ampel
letztendlich dann wirklich beeinflusst
oder die oppositionsparteien sorgen muss
oder wie ist ihr fazit grundsätzlich
würde ich mal sagen
gewisse stabilisierung für den
sozialdemokratischen teil der ampel auf
jeden fall so ein ergebnis so klein das
land auch ist ist ein knaller für eine
partei damit können sie eine weile
hausieren gehen wir haben ja jahrelang
über den cdu sieg 2017 im saarland
geredet und ja gut weiß was rein
geheimnis also man kann auch über einen
saarland wahlergebnis lange reden und
sie lange und das wird die spd
sicherlich tun sie werden ja auch
geklappt wenn sie es nicht täten die
beiden anderen ampel parteien werden
sagen erinnern wir uns gar nicht mehr so
genau daran dass seine wahl war kommen
wieder andere zeiten ansonsten heißt es
natürlich für die cdu das also märz muss
diese zeit der zerrissenheit für die ich
sozusagen sowohl tobias hans ein
teilnehmer war die muster so schnell wie
möglich hinter sich bringen die an
kredit dafür bekommen also mit wieviel
94,9 prozent zum vorsitzenden gewählt
werden im dritten anlauf das ist ein
riesen kredit und ich glaube dahinter
steht der wunsch bitte jetzt wir müssen
jetzt mal gemeinsam handeln schluss mit
zanken das wird er daraus der wette sich
noch mal ein bisschen bestätigt fühlen
aber auf dem weg ist er sowieso
unterwegs mit der bitte um eine kurze
antwort
also ich kann dem natürlich vollkommen
zustimmen ich glaube auch dass der
fertige mehr als das weiß aber es kommt
tatsächlich andere zeiten also hendrik
wüst ist ein kandidat der jedenfalls
noch nicht abgeschlagen ist also das
sagen die umfragen ist nicht so wie wir
tobias hans absehbar da der winter ist
ein erfolgreicher ministerpräsident und
außerdem werden fdp und grüne sich
überlegen dass sie vielleicht auch auf
einer anderen art und weise auf einem
anderen spielfeld deutlich machen wir
könnten auch mit jemand anderem regieren
olaf solltest du uns zu stark werden
oder gar nicht mehr auf uns hören was ja
passieren kann also in hamburg ist ja
mal passiert haben die grünen sich
beschwert dann wollen wir das vielleicht
doch mal weiter mit deiner günther
versuchen und dann sitzen wir hier und
sagen wir ja guck mal die cdu ist doch
wieder da gut dann schauen wir was da am
8 reisen durch die waren schließlich
erscheint was ihr durch bedanke mich
sehr herzlich hier für die diskussion
mit ihnen beiden und ich bedanke mich
bei insel hat sich fürs zuschauen das
war unsere phoenix wahlrunde im laufe
des abends werden wir sie natürlich mit
aktuellen und weiter auf dem laufenden
halten und auch morgen vormittag ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und bedanke mich für ihr interesse
[Musik]